now certain plants have the capacity to
cause cancer cells to commit suicide it's
very interesting so you may have heard
of sulfurophane which is a phytonutrient
that's in broccoli sprouts broccoli cauliflower
kale brussels sprouts cabbage bok choy
and other cruciferous vegetables and even john
hopkins university attempted to get the patents
on broccoli sprouts because they did the studies
on sulforaphane finding that it's anti-cancer
so the question is if these phytonutrients
like sulforaphane have the ability to cause
cancer cells to commit suicide do they do
the same thing with our cells okay well i'm
going to show you a specific section of
the study that talks about this concept
so this is a quote taken from the study i'm going
to put it down below okay sulforaphane selectively
inhibited hgac activity and what is that well htac
activity is really just an enzyme that affects the
dna stability causing the dna to be very unstable
in a cell okay and induced which means triggered
p21 expression now what that does p21
expression mean that means apoptosis this
this is the term that describes a cell committing
suicide okay so sulforaphane inhibits this enzyme
that normally keeps the dna stable so now
this dna becomes unstable and triggers
the cell to commit suicide okay in benign
hyperplasia what is that tumors okay and
cancer cells while it only cause a transient
which is kind of a not a long-term thing it's
a short-term type thing decrease in hdac activity
and did not affect the p21 expression in normal
cells and this is why they said selectively okay
so you're not going to have to worry about getting
cancer from eating these plants because it's
selective it has the ability to differentiate
and go after the cancer cells and leave your cells
alone and so the question is why did a plant even
come up with this chemical in the first place well
plants have enemies bacteria insects that type of
thing so that's the defense mechanism and so it's
pretty safe for our bodies unless you have some
gut damage where there's leaky gut for example
but if you don't have gut issues i would highly
recommend having some of these foods on a regular
basis as they have a huge benefit of selectively
causing the cancer cell to commit suicide hey
before you go real quick i have a course entitled
how to bulletproof your immune system it's a
free course i want you to take it and here's why
here's you here is your environment everyone
is focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here what about
strengthening your immune system that's what's
missing this course will show you how to
bulletproof yourself and so you can tolerate
and resist your environment much better by
strengthening your own immune system i put
a link down in the description right down
below check it out and get signed up today